سفاره الانذار تدوي في معظم انحايه
اوكرانيا ومنورات جويه روسيه بلا روسيات
تنطلق اليوم
النظام الايراني يعقب السجينات بحبوب
الاعصاب في سجن شيراز وحفيد الخميني يدعو
لتسليم السلطه للشعب
اجراءات جديده متوقعه اليوم في بريطانيا
تشمل منحه الشرطه سلطات اوسع لمواجهه
الاضطرابات
[موسيقى]
اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى هذه النشره
الاخباريه من العربيه الى الرئيس
الاوكراني
اكثر من 30 شخصا في المبنى الذي استهدفته
القوات الروسيه في دنيترو مازال مجهولا
مشيرا الى انه تم انقاذه 10 اشخاص حتى
الان وان عمليات الانقاذ مستمره
استنونا
لا يزال مصير اكثر من 30 شخصا مجهولا في
المبنى الذي استهدفه الارهابيون بضربه
صاروخيه لقد تم انقاذه عشرات الاشخاص من
تحت الاوقات من بينهم سته اطفال نحن نقاتل
من اجل كل شخص و عمليات الانقاذ ستستمر
طالمكان هناك ادنى فرصه لانقاذهم
[موسيقى]
هذا وتجري روسيا وبيلا روسيا اليوم
مناورات جويه مشتركه وصفتها الدولتان
بالدفاعيه ولتحضير لصديق اي هجوم محتمل
افادت مصادر اعلاميه اوكرانيه بان سفاره
الانذار دوه الليله البارحه في عدد من
المناطق الاوكرانيه فيما قال مراسل
العربيه في اوكرانيا ان القتلى ما زال
مستمرا في بلده سوليدار بحسب ما صرحت به
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ودعت الوزاره
الاوكرانيين الى عدم الالتفات للدعايه
الروسيه لما تشكله من تاثير سلبي على
معنويات المقاتلين كما اكدت وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه قيام قواتها بصد عدد من
الهجمات الروسيه التي استهدفت باخمود
وكريمينا ولوكا
اكد الامين العام لحل في شمال الاطلسي
ستور تمبرج ان دول غربيه سترسل لي
اوكرانيا شحنات جديده من الاسلحه الثقيله
وقال ستوتامبيرج لصحيفه المانيا قبل
اجتماعي هذا الاسبوع لمجموعه الاتصال
للدفاع عن اوكرانيا قال ان التعاهدات
الاخيره بتسليم اسلحه ثقيله مهمه
لاوكرانيا
وستنفذ خلال المستقبل القريب مشيرا الى في
الوقت ذاته الى ان المرحله الحاليه من
الحرب تعد حاسمه
تشالنجر 2 العمود الفقري لقوه الدبابات في
الجيش البريطاني وهي واحده من اربع دبابات
قتاليه رئيسيه طورتها دول حلف الناتو لخوض
الحروب فهل ستقدر هذه الدبابات على مواجهه
دبابه تي 9 الروسيه احدى افضل دبابات
العالم من حيث الحمايه والتدريع في ساحه
المعركه باوكرانيا مشاهدينا طول دبابات
تشالنجر 2 يتجاوز الاحد 10 مترا ووزنها 2
62 طنا ونصف دبابه ثقيله الحركه سرعتها
تصل الى 59 كلم في الساعه ويصل مداها الى
450 كلم اما تي 9 فطولها وطولها هيكلها
اقل من سبعه امتار ووزنها اخاف بكثير ويصل
الى نحو ثمانيه واربعين طنا من ذخائر
والافراد قدره عاليه على المناوره على
السرعه قصوى تصلوا الى 70 كم في الساعه
بينما يصل مداها الى 500 كلم تشالنجر 2
مشاهدينا دبابه مصممه لمهاجمه الدبابات
الاخرى وتدميرها تحتوي على دروع ثقيله
ومدفع رايسي من عيار 22 ملم باثنين وخمسين
قذيفه بالاضافه طبعا لمدفعين اخرين بمقدار
4000 طلقه فيما المدفع الرئيسي للدبابه
الروسيه فهو من عيار
125 ملم كمان نشاهد هنا اجمالي الطلقات مع
مدفعين اخرين
2340 طلقه ومجهزه بصواريخ موجهه مداها
خمسه كيلومترات تتميز تي 9 بالنظام قليل
للتحكم في اطلاق النار هنا الدبابه
باستطاعتها البحث عن الاهداف وتعقب هذه
الاهداف في وضع الثبات او الحركه ليلا او
نهارا ايضا كانت
بالعوده مشاهدينا الى تشالنجر هي مصممه
لعبور التضاريس المفتوحه
وتمثلها بذلك الدبابه الروسيه ذات القدره
العاليه على اجتياز الموانع الطبيعيه
سيتصاعد في حال لم تتوقف استفزازات حزب
العمال الكردستاني واضاف انه يجب على
السويد تسليم 130 مطلوبا للمصادقه على
عضويتها في نيته
كشفت انشطه الايرانيه ليلى حسين زاده التي
تم الافراج عنها مؤقتا بكفاله ماليه كشفت
في تغريدات على تويتر عن الحال الماساويه
للنساء في سجن شيراز ووصفت ناشطه
الايرانيه استخدام حبوب الاعصاب مجهوله
الاسم للسجينات بانها جريمه مروعه حيث ادت
هذه الادويه الى تشنجات عصبيه بين سجينات
دعا علي الخميني حفيد المرشد الايراني
الاول في كلمه له خلال احتفال ديني في
مدينه النجف العراقيه دعى الى تسليم
الحكومه الى الشعب الايراني ونقل موقعه
جمران عن علي خميني قوله اذا تمكنا من
تسليم الحكومه بمجملها الى الشعب الايراني
فيمكن القول على وجه اليقين انهم سيطبقون
الاسلام بشكل افضل منا على الاطلاق وتابع
علي خميني مدافعا عن الاحتجاجات قائلا ان
هذا الشعب صبور لكنه محتاج وكلنا محتجون
هذا هو يوصل النظام الايراني انتاج سياسه
الاعدام في حق العديد من الشخصيات البارزه
وهذه المره مع المواطن البريطاني
الايرانيه الاصل علي رضا اكبري
بعد اعدام علي رضا اكبر المثير للجدل
وردود الفعل الغربيه المهدده تظهر تطورات
الاحداث في ايران ان عمليه الاعدام ما هي
الا مقدمه لصدع المتوقع في هيكل النظام
الايراني
وليس ادل على ذلك ما سرب من حديث اجبري مع
القاضي المكلف بمحاكمته
فواحده من التهم التي اعدم اكبر بسببها هي
حصوله على معلومات سريه عن الدوله من امين
المجلس الاعلى للامن القومي علي شمخاني
مقابل زجاجه عطر وقميص
وهنا كان سؤال اكبر البدايه للقاضي اذا
كان شمخاني سرب هذه المعلومات اليه فلماذا
لا يحاكم معي
لكن رد القاضي كان مفاجئا اذ قال للشاكي
ليس لدي القوه لاستدعاء شمساني لكنني
سادمرك انت
طبعا كل هذا بالاضافه لما تعرض له اكبر من
تعذيب لفتره طويله ان تزعت خلالها
اعترافاته قصرا
السؤال الذي يدور الان بين دوائر
المتابعين هل كان اكبري هو الهدف ام شم
خان نفسه
ايران انترناشونال قالت وفقا للوثائق حصلت
عليها من داخل الحرس الثوري ان الاطاحه
بشمخاني هي الهدف الاكبر مما حدث لاكبره
وحتى الشبكات التابعه للحرس الثوري على
تليجرام تناولت معلومات عن اقاله الرجل
لكن المتحدث باسم المجلس الاعلى للامن
القومي نفى ذلك تماما بل ان الحديث امتد
الى خليفته القادمه وتم التركيز على وزير
الداخليه احمد وحيد باعتباره صاحب اكبر
الفرص
ويرى معارضون ان النظام قد يكون في مرحله
محاسبه من يعتقد انهم خذوه خلال موجه
الاحتجاجات الاخيره
الى التدخل لاخماد الاحتجاجات
ووعد بالسعي لتقديم مزيد من الحريه وتحقيق
بعض مطالب المحتجدين هذا النهج لم يرق
لصقور النظام الذين راوا على الدوام ان
القبضه الحديديه هي الحل لعلاج كل المشكله
سويت شوارع ازاي
[موسيقى]
النوويه
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
شركه عيسى للادويه تقدم طلبا للموافقه على
عقار الزهايمر في اليابان
حياكم الله وضع رئيس النظام السوري بشار
الاسد شروطه لاعاده تطبيع العلاقات مع
تركيا ابرزها انهاء الوجود التركيه على
الاراضي السوريه
واعاده بذلك ما سالت تعديل بنود اتفاقيه
اضراب بين انقره ودمشق للواجهه مجددا وهو
مطلب تركي بالطبع الذي يدعو الى توسيع
الاتفاقيه لتشمل حق الدخول مسافه 30 كلم
بدلا من خمسه وفقا لنسخه عام
19980 وفقا لمصادر سوريا
[موسيقى]
تعتزموا حكومه رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريش
السوناتا الاعلان عن مقترحات الجديده
لمواجهه الاحتجاجات ومنح الشرطه سلطات
اوسع لمنع حدوث اضرابات خطيره واصدره
الحكومه تشريعها لمعالجتها الامر في العام
الماضي لكنها تخطط للمضي قدما في مجموعه
جديده من القوانين تعرف باسم قانون النظام
العام وتريد الحكومه تعديل مشروع القانون
قبل ان يصبح نافذه لتوسيع التعريف
القانوني للاضراب الخطيبه واعطاء الشرطه
مزيدا من المرونه وتقول الحكومه ان
القوانين الجديده في حال اقرارها ستعني
انه بامكان الشرطه ايقاف الاحتجاجات التي
تصل الى مستوى التخريب بشكل السباقي
اشار تقرير صحفي لسن دايز البريطانيه الى
احتماليه اجراء مصالحه بين الامير هاري
والعائله الملكيه البريطانيه قبل تتويج
الملك تشارلز في مايو المقبل وذلك بعد نشر
مذكره الامير هاري تحت عنوان البديل ووفقا
لمصدر مقرب من الامير هاري والعائله
الملكيه فان المصالحه ممكنه وان كانت
تتطلب تجاوزه عقبات عده
من باب المصالحه قد يعود الامير هاري الى
اروقه
لكنها قد تكون عاجله قبل تتويج الملك
تشارلز الثالث مايو المقبل وفقا لصحيفه
ساندي تايمز البريطانيه
مصادر مقربه من الملك تشارلز والامير هاري
ترى ان اجتماعا قد يعقد بينهما في حضور
وريث العرش الامير ويليام خلال الاشهر
المقبله
رغبه حقيقيه لجلوس الشقيقين مع الملك
تشارلز في غرفه واحده
ومصالحه ممكنه لكن تقف في طريقها عقبات
حسب تقرير صنداي تايمز تتطلب المصالحه
الاعتراف باخطاء الماضي من قبل الجميع وهو
ما يحتاج الى مرونه قد يفتقدها هاري
الراغب في الحصول على اعتذار من العائله
الملكيه لزوجته الى جانب المساءله قبل
المصالحه
العقبه الثانيه تتمثل في نيران كتاب
البديل التي جعلت الامير ويليام يحترق
داخليا حسب وصف المصدر المقرب من الجانبين
فهل يستطيع وريث العرش الحفاظ على هدوء
بعد تركومات الخلاف مع شقيقه هاري
غياب الثقه المتبادله يظل حاجزا ليس فقط
من اجل اتمام المصالحه ولكن من اجل الجلوس
اولا فبحسب المصادر ينبغي وجود افراد من
الاسره يثق فيهم هاري حتى لا يعتقد انه
يتعرض ما
عقبه نحو المصالحه يسعى القصر الى تدليلها
وملك يرغب في تهيئه اجواء طبيعيه خلال
مراسم التتويج في مايو المقبل وان لم تهدا
الاجواء فقد تتحول الى مصدر الهاء وتشتيت
وفقا لمقربين من العائله الملكيه
علي السمان العربيه
[تصفيق]
الجديده في منزل الرئيس الامريكي يضع
مستقبل السياسيه تحت المجهر ويعطي الفرصه
للجمهوريين لتوجيه التهامي للرئيس
الامريكي
وثائقي سريه اخرى تزيد اللقطه واشاره
الاستفهام حول الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
فبعد الاوراق الحساسه التي وجدت في مكتبه
والتي تعود لفتره شغله منصب نائب الرئيس
خمس صفحات اضافيه عثر عليها البيت الابيض
في منزل بيضتون في ولايه ديلر لتتم
احالتها لوزاره العدل السؤال الذي تطرحه
وزاره العدل الامريكيه ان كان بيضا
منتهيكا للقانون ام لا في الحالتين سيواجه
تحقيقات قضائيه بينما الرجل في ذروه شعبيه
بعد انجازاته في المنصب حتى الان
انا اخذ الوثائق السريه والمواد السريه
على محمل الجده نتعاون بالكامل مع وزاره
العدل
اثر جدلا خاصه بعد التكتم على وجودها حتى
انتهاء انتخابات التجديد النصفي التي جرت
في نوفمبر الماضي وتثير تكهنات حول مستقبل
بيض السياسي بيض نفسه الذي انتقد عندما
مسئوليه الرئيس السابق
لدى كشف الوثائق السريه التي احتفظ بها في
منزله في فلوريدا
فرصه تفتح اوسع الابواب للجمهوريين لرمي
التهم على الرئيس الحالي واضعين الحالتين
في كفتين ميزان متوازيتين
ورغم ان بعيدا ابدى تعاونه في القضيه عكس
ترامب الا ان ذلك لن يبعده عن التحقيقات
والاسئله العديده خاصه بعد تاخير الكشف
ليس الجمهوريون وحدهم بل بعض من
الديمقراطيين انتقدوا التهمه التي قدمها
بيضا على طبق من ذهب للحزب المنافس الى
عمر العربيه
اعلنت منظمه انقذوا الاطفال لانها ستستانف
عملها في افغانستان وذلك بعد وعود من
طالبان بعدم التعرض لموظفاتها وقالت
المنظمه في بيان لها انها تلقت تاكيدات من
طالبان بان موظفاتها يمكنهن العمل دون
عوائق مشيرتان الى ان المجالات التي
ستستانف العمل فيها تشمل مجالات الصحه
والتغذيه والخدمات التعليميه
الصراع بين روسيا والدول الغربيه يحتدم في
عده مجالات واماكن ومنها القطب الشمالي
المتجمد هو الموقع الاستراتيجي للقطب وما
يسخر به من معادن ثمينه ومصادر طاقه
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين اواخر عامي
موتشنا لكاسحه الجليد النوويه ياكوتيا
ولكن اللقطه الاهم هي اعلانه عن البدء في
بناء كاسحه اكبر واحدث سيفوق طولها
المئتين متر و بقدره ازاحه تفوق 70000 طن
ولكن اقوى مافيها هو رمزيه اسمها فقد
سماها بوتين روسيا
اعاده عن امتلاكهم لقواعد عسكريه في القطب
الشمالي داب الرسول سنوات على تنظيم
مناورات في القطب لاعداد قوات قوامها
الالاف على اساليب الحرب في المناطق
المتجمده من جانبه حلف شمال الاطلسي ينظم
برامج تدريب لقوات الدول الاعضاء حتى تكون
قادره على مجابهه التفوق الروسي
البيت الابيض كان قد نشر وثيقه عنوانها
استراتيجيه القطب الشمالي التي تمتد لعشر
سنوات مقبله وترتكز على اربع اسوس زياده
الوجود العسكري تطوير الدفاعات الجويه
زياده عدد كاسات الجليد وتطوير قدرات
الرصد الجوي والخرائط
الصراع في القطب لا يدور حول السيطره على
مساحه ضخمه من الجليد بل يتمحور حول ما
يوجد تحتها من ثروات معدنيه في السويد
مثلا بدات بالاستثمار في مناجم المعادن
النادره المستخدمه في صناعه الرقائق
الالكترونيه
وبطاريات السيارات الكهربائيه كما ان
الدراسات اظهرت امكانيه وجود كميات مهمه
من الطاقه
المواجهه بين روسيا والغرب في القطب
الشمالي حاليا ما تزال في مراحلها الاولى
نظرا لانشغال الجميع بالحرب في اوكرانيا
حسب مراقبين ولكنها مرشحه للتصعيد في اي
وقت لانه روسيا تعتبر القطب مفتاحا لامنها
القومي
وتنميتها الاقتصاديه
انس نماسي العربيه
حوادث طيران بشعه تحدث في نيبال كل عامين
تقريبا تنتهي بكوارث واعداد ضحايا كبيره
تضاف لها حادثه امس التي اسفرت عن مقتل 72
من نوعها
على ماذا اعوام كثيره
منذ عام
1946 في العام 1992
76 راكبا على متن طائره باكستانيه فقدت
حياتهم في العام 2012
في العام 2014
بالعامي 2016 تحطم طائره توين اوتر ومقتل
جميع ركبها وعددهم 23
في العام 2018 مقتل 49 شخصا بعد تقدم
طائره ميغاليه امريكيه
اعلن رئيس بلديه نيويورك
في المدينه للحافلات المحمله بالمهاجرين
وذلك خلال زيارته الى مدينه الباسو
الواقعه على الحدود مع المكسيك وانتقد ادم
زي اداره الرئيس بايدا قائلا ان الوقت حان
لكي تؤدي الحكومه الوطنيه مهامها بشان
ازمه المهاجرين على الحدود الجنوبيه
للولايات المتحده
ادمز اعتبر ان الحفلات القادمه من ولايات
يديرها جمهوريون الى مدن يديرها
ديمقراطيون ادت الى تفاقم ازمه الاسكان
والمشردين في نيويورك وقد تكلفها ما يصل
الى مليار دولار
تقدمت شركه عيسى اليابانيه لادويه للادويه
بطلب الحصول على موافقه الجهات التنظيميه
على عقار لكاني ماب لعلاج مرض الزهايمر
وهو العقار الذي طورته بالتعاون مع شركه
بيوجن الامريكيه وكان العقار نجح خلال
التجارب السريريه في اطفاء التدهور
المعرفي والوظيفي لدى المصابين بالمراحل
المبكره من المرض بنسبه 27%
الى العناوين
صافره الانذار تدوي في معظم انحاء
اوكرانيا ومناورات جويه روسيه بلا روسيه
تنطلق اليوم
النظام الايراني يعاقب السجينات بحبوب
الاعصاب في سجن شيراز وحفيد الخميني يدعو
لتسليم السلطه الى الشعب
اجراءات جديده اليوم في بريطانيا تشمل
منحه الشرطه سلطات اوسع لمواجهه
الاضطرابات
شكرا لكم لطيب المتابعه القاكم بعد دقائق
[موسيقى]